we're seeing the deportation happen
right now these guys just got off the
bus they're handcuffed from their hands
and their wrists officers are removing
those shackles putting them back on the
bus and then they'll cross over to
Mexico but what happens after
deportation we've reported on the
arrests of undocumented immigrants and
what it's like to visit your loved ones
in detention but not much is known about
what takes place after someone is sent
back to the country where they were born
we cross the border to find out what
life looks like in Mexico for those
who've just been deported
these guys just got off the bus they
were deported today you can see they
have their stuff in their hands and we
want to see if we can talk to him
[Music]
normally a girl may wander your son in
the government a national survey dos
meses Alejo original reporta que vas a
hacer ahora Dora me boyo
yes hola amigo
those with money hop on buses or in cabs
others are taken to shelters and
government vans to get meals and
services the first stop for many seeking
help is the Kino border initiative so we
offer here two meals a day clothing
pasture support and a variety of
services thanks to other nonprofit
organizations in the area they give me
an idea of who comes here who are the
people that need these services the
majority have just crossed the desert we
also see people have been and this has
been increasing people have been living
in United States without documents for
many years maybe 25 30 years perhaps
longer and so they're really from the
United States for them I'd say for many
in Mexico is really a foreign country
it's a very disorienting and traumatic
experience for them
Mayra had been living in the US for 30
years she chose to be deported after her
epileptic seizures weren't properly
treated an avoid attention center what
was the crime that you committed I was
raped I
took the knife the he was assaulting me
with I defended myself I cut him and
because the assault happened on his home
where his family was in other rooms and
they will testify it against me I went
to jail while on probation Myra was
turned over to ice for an expired green
card she's now in a country she hasn't
seen since she was 12
deportations are expected to rise under
President Trump the shelters we visited
haven't seen higher numbers yet but they
have noticed that more of the people
being deported had lived in the US for
decades
recently deported men who need a place
to sleep are taken by the government to
this neighborhood
here at the Juan Bosco shelter Gilda
Loreto and her husband Juan have been
feeding and housing deportees since in
1982 this is a Mexican government right
now dropping off a bunch of people
who've recently been deported and
they're coming in here for some shelter
on this night we watched two different
groups of men dropped off those who'd
been held in u.s. detention and those
who've been caught trying to cross the
border the detainees had their
belongings returned to them in garbage
bags while those caught crossing still
had their backpacks
Jose was a permanent resident who lived
in the US for 39 years
he was caught for drug possession and
chose to be deported rather than remain
in detention this is the only stuff you
brought with you to Mexico this is all
you have in your life at this point
what's in the bag it's just uh stuff
from from the attention Center my Bible
sweater got picked up with another Bible
you ever think you'd see the day where
you're carrying your life around in a
trash bag not like this I mean I know I
know I was messing up but I don't think
I was messing up to a point where I'm
gonna get deported like this you know so
you have no money you have no cellphone
how I do plan to go about getting on
your two feet again here just hopefully
find some work you know help out here
and there just do our jobs type of thing
and but money why is he I gotta really
start from scratch yes cuz dirty that's
a reality those like Roberto know all
too well he was deported under President
Obama in 2012 Mira como eres maneuver
Casa amigo payment
pero este pais a penis boy Gondo aquí de
Saavedra mo de nada por que como esta
toda so ya been a sago mini Sumiko Honda
yo a smear a semi me cocina Chiquita
para Pena's voir empezando de hecho todo
es lo que para darle que tengan material
para para troja ya Kazami de cámara de
una Luz epode le can Roberto lived in
Tucson for 15 years and worked
installing air conditioners una vez
cuando venía de me trabajo me de - oh no
la patrulla la patrulla de del de tus on
Perez yo Trey una caja de mi carro
estado que no tenia licencia de
Americana what do you want Americans to
understand about people like you who
want to be in the US and who were there
working but got deported yo entiendo que
no todos los emigrant a son so no nice
Toso son whenas person on Oh Ida todo de
hecho puede
poor algo también tienen su seguridad
Estados Unidos por que puedas por el
terrorize mo tráfico drove esto es o por
este lado yo entiendo no pero por
ejemplo personas por ejemplo que no de
tienen chintan a new record criminal yo
estaba siendo miss taxes yo yo eva
Corrientes siempre con todo y trabajaba
ba no se yo nunca taupe or lemma C Y me
deportable
buenos días a como que me de mas como
que me dama sentimiento como que me
Dante stessa me say or esta en estados
unidos C no puede venir aquí que me voy
Megara Westar doe science ahora
impression Despero tiempo perdido us a
dino mejor no voy a poner a quien a
trabajar aqui un padre bueno no se
throughout Mexico there are countless
others like Roberto people who lived in
the US for decades and are now having to
rebuild their lives it's likely that
under Trump there'll be many more to
come
so that's a glimpse of what life looks
like after someone is deported to Mexico
make sure you check out our entire
immigration series which also looks at
the fears undocumented folks in the US
have of arrests and detention